diese bedrohung die uns ja unserer
generation wieder erst ins bewusstsein
rücken muss wie ordnet die ein
historiker ein wie groß ist die
bedrohung gemessen an dem was wir aus
dem kalten krieg was unsere eltern aus
dem kalten krieg kennen
wir schon sagen wir leben natürlich in
äußerst interessanten unerwarteten
zeiten bis jetzt ist es doch so dass man
vielleicht aus historischer sicht sagen
kann wir müssen einfach noch abwarten
was genau jetzt eigentlich wirklich
passiert natürlich spitzt sich der
konflikt zu sowohl in der ukraine als
auch rhetorisch mit dem mit dem westen
wie weit das noch genau gehen wird ist
die große frage momentan ist es noch
schwer eine wirkliche parallel zu ziehen
zu einem möglichen kalten krieg der
vielleicht heiß geworden wäre allein
aufgrund der tatsache dass wir momentan
noch nicht die nato involviert haben er
hat denn ihrer ansicht nach die macht
über den atom koffer also gibt es auch
in diesen strukturen menschen oder
strukturen um putin herum er die diesen
schritt verlangsamen könnten
das system in russland ist so gegliedert
dass
atomwaffen wirklich scharf machen zu
können noch starten zu können benötigt
man zwei personen es gibt drei atom
koffer wie man das ja zum beispiel auch
aus den usa kennt also drei atom koffer
einer davon liegt bei putin selber ein
anderer liegt beim verteidigungsminister
und der dritte befindet sich in den
händen des generalstabschefs und zwei
von diesen drei müssen quasi
gleichzeitig scharf geschaltet werden
damit man wirklich nuklearwaffen
abschießen kann es gibt hier über große
diskussion momentan auch unter meinen
kollegen und akademischen kreisen der
allgemeine tenor die man da vielleicht
aufnehmen kann ist dass insbesondere der
russische verteidigungsminister
vielleicht wenn man so sagen möchte eher
geneigt wäre seinen koffer schafstalls
als vielleicht der generalstabschef das
sind aber alles momentan spekulation so
weit sind wir auch noch lange nicht wenn
man sich einmal anschaut wo eigentlich
genau stehen auf der eskalation stufe
dies in russland gibt dann sind wir
momentan noch da nicht wirklich im
klaren darüber was in russland genau wie
es passiert ist gibt in russland vier
stufen der eskalation
man bewegt sich von der stoffe normal so
bis zur stufe erhöhte alarmbereitschaft
danach kommt so genannte militärische
gefahr und erst dann kommt die die volle
mobilisierung und erst zu diesem
zeitpunkt werden die raketen wirklich
auch mit koordinaten bestückt und danach
abgefeuert das interessante an der
ganzen diskussion momentanen der lage
momentan ist das protein eine besondere
gefechtsbereitschaft
angeordnet hat diese findet sich
eigentlich gar nicht in
eskalationsstufen deswegen wird gerade
auch in westlichen hauptstädten zb auch
hier in london
meistens gesagt dass es sich eigentlich
momentan eher um eine rhetorische frage
haben routine möchte daran erinnern dass
russland über nuklearwaffen verfügt er
möchte den westen daran erinnern dass
man keine zu starken sanktionen einfach
dass man in anführungszeichen nichts
großes gegen russland unternimmt da
russland diese möglichkeiten der
eskalation dennoch hat letzte frage herr
strom jetzt haben wir in kiew gesehen
die menschen wissen dann natürlich ganz
genau wo sie hingehen müssen im fall
eines alarms der ja ja stündlich da im
grunde ausbricht die menschen sind das
mittlerweile gewohnt an kriegstag sechs
wir fragen so ein bisschen wie wir das
eigentlich bei uns also haben wir solche
pläne haben wir genügend bunker haben
wir den ich alle zurückgebaut seit der
zeit des kalten krieges
die antwort ist eigentlich ganz einfach
pläne gibt es ein so gut wie keiner mehr
da und wäre in deutschland auf eine
ähnliche situation eigentlich in
keinster weise vorbereitet sie sich
schon sagen mit dem ende des kalten
krieges wohl eigentlich alle diese pläne
eingemottet
abgeschafft und deutschland wäre von der
infrastruktur von der versorgung in
keinster weise auf eine ähnliche
situation vorbereitet wie man sie gerade
in der ukraine findet jetzt haben wir
heute früher strohen das doch ganz kurz
diese beeindruckenden und gleichzeitig
bedrohlichen bilder aus der ukraine
gesehen ein 64 kilometer konvoi von
putins armee auf dem weg richtung kiew
lag können wir die bilder nochmal ganz
kurz zeigen was erkennen sie auf diesen
satelliten aufnahmen die sie heute früh
in der nacht auch gesehen haben
man sieht auf diesen bildern wie schon
seit 64 kilometer unglaublich lang eine
unglaublich massierung von kräften wenn
man versucht jetzt wirklich in diesem
bereich den schwerpunkt sind nicht nur
kollegen sondern auch die entscheidung
zu erzwingen man man kann auf den
bildern unter anderem starke theorie
kontingente sehen das lässt darauf
schliessen eventuell man muss also
wieder raus abwarten was kommt dass das
die russen jetzt vielleicht geneigter
sind artillerie auch massierte
einzusetzen als sie es bisher getan
haben die russische militärdoktrin
verlangt eigentlich gegen den starken
einsatz von von ati kräften man hat dies
gerade in den in den bevölkerungszentren
noch nicht so gesehen wie man das
eigentlich aus dem der klassischen
russischen
militärdoktrin einiger waren könnte der
grund dafür ist wahrscheinlich dass wir
noch russischer seite doch versucht hat
dir die zivilen verluste so niedrig wie
möglich zu halten womöglich um nicht
noch mehr andere länder gegen sich
aufzubringen
es ist besteht eventuell die möglichkeit
dass ich dies jetzt vielleicht bald
ändern wird man sich das ja auch schon
im osten die berichte der nacht zeigen
ja dass das dort auch schon mehr mit mit
artillerie und auch mit raketen auf die
städte geschossen wird als man das in
der anfangsphase des kindes gesehen hat
und das problem ist natürlich dass
artillerie aber immer noch königliche
präzisionswaffe ist und das bedeutet
sollte es dazu kommen dass man zu einem
massierte im einsatz der artillerie
kommt das dann wahrscheinlich auch mit
höheren zivilen verlusten rechnen und
danke herzlich an den militärexperten
militärhistoriker matthias strom von der
uni buckingham im lande danke danke